once again I think it's my duty to share
these phone calls between President
Barack Obama and president elect Donald
Trump give listen listen you can't just
go talking to the leader of Taiwan I
will be totally honest with you I didn't
realize Taiwan was a real country
so I just figured it was like China's
own version of Chinatown or something
hello Hey who gives the State of the
Union speech this year you me there
isn't one this year No then how about we
give what together we can finish each
other's sentences
I don't really burn then I was born in
this country being God but he goes here
hey Barack I just saw something on the
news that killed me to the core world
woman well apparently a man that you
grew father killed Santa Claus due to a
loophole he now has to become Santa
Claus idiots no idea what he's doing
that's the plot of the Santa Claus it's
a movie starring Tim out I just does
that ding troops in the North Pole
Donald Trump damn it
I was a racist I said of course that my
best friend is black okay
I was talking about you we're not best
friend that we talk on the phone all the
time because you call me but only best
fresh call each other while they're
doing number two - your bear road
very important question what do you want
for christmas
oh you don't have to give me anything
seriously anything you want just David a
very rich okay
maintain Obamacare Apple TV it is
favorite what are you doing
Donald I'm very busy this better be good
oh it's okay I guess I could call you
back there's an important it's very
important but you're so busy I'll just
call you later
no just make it quick it's okay just go
ahead what right what was the name of
the actress who plays Melissa McCarthy's
Bob on Mike & Molly
movie hurt melodia it was fuzzy Kurt
[Applause]
you